on a scale of zero to ten as far as a
freestyler goes where where are you
putting you at
zero are you a straight zero i i know my
lanes yeah and i'm in a bunch of them
yeah yeah hitting a little browser
wrapping like get in on this like that
ain't happening have you ever heard have
you heard i mean have you even attempted
it
i'll make fun of him uh with some of it
but no never
not my thing yeah it's it's a certain
skill set
you know yeah i don't have it either
yeah when you bring out you bring out
the
guitar sometimes oh yeah at the end of
my show so man
i always do an hour of straight stand up
and then the last 15 or 20 minutes
because you know a couple years ago more
than a couple
but i always wanted to bring the guitar
out but what i was
i was too nervous about what other
comics stuff to do at the store though
yeah and i was it they showed up with a
guitar yeah
but i was too nervous about what other
comics were going to say and then i was
like
they're not buying tickets to my show no
do where the [ __ ] you want i'm doing
what i'm sure
and i'm doing an hour of stand up first
yeah so you're checking that box
yeah man i'm doing it and then and then
but this is something you're talking
about lanes this is something that i've
always wanted to do i've always always
got time to
think about think of sandler yeah adam
sandler's special yeah by the way that's
special
you saw that special yeah i that special
was one of my favorites
oh thank god i thought you're gonna hate
on it no no no no one he i love
i defend him to the [ __ ] grave i
don't know how you bash him
i don't know what's there to back became
a cool thing to do it's kind of like
nickelback
right yeah like they got so popular it's
like the thing to do like people hate on
drake
and they get so big it's like the cool
thing to hate on them yeah
it's it's like coldplay went from the
coolest band ever and like you listen to
coldplay i'm like
yeah actually yeah i still do because we
liked them last month did we like them
last month yeah yeah what happened
they do something together it's so
fickle
it's so [ __ ] up are you are you doing
anything for the super bowl
well dude i'm shooting my special on
saturday or sunday
saturday oh thank you so the night
before i'm super excited about this man
so i'm streaming
yeah tell us what it is so a couple
months ago two months ago
i found my very first comedy cd because
you're moving i'm sure you moved up yeah
exactly and i found like they were like
i think i only made 10 or 25 even back
then and i was like let me listen to
this
and i listened to it and it was filled
with good premises but not a lot of
great jokes
because how old how old would those
jokes be they're like 16 years old
right and so i was like let me rewrite
this
not not like punch it up but rewrite it
and uh same premises but you know and
are the premises relate to 2021
no i keep the premise kind of because i
keep the premises the same but like
they're still about my kids
and and i do incorporate like more of
what i think now so if i'm giving
examples
it's more current examples and things
like that but to rewrite it under this
scope
was so cool and there were so many jokes
that i would get cancelled for
really but i'm telling them when it
comes to like transgender
uh you know i tell look i have a lot my
jokes okay
i'll tell you one of them please all
right so so
i i have a teenage daughter and um
you know at 14 is around the age that
you know she started dressing like a
[ __ ] and and i don't
want my daughter to dress him like a
[ __ ] you know i mean i want her friends
too because that's kind of hot but
come on pool party at mr wolf's house
everybody come on everybody
so i that joke i loved that joke but
like
it's hard to tell that joke now but i
think it is but i wouldn't even tell
that joke now
like if i the way so when i listen to
that i'm like that joke's fine
but honestly my first thought is wow
it's so much different between
like boys and girls like i would never
have that issue with my son no the
world's a lot
more scary for girls right right and so
that's kind of where my mind went now
you know what i really found was that so
back then i was worried about punchlines
and i think i was a better actual punch
line writer back then
because that's where my brain went and
so i would hit a punch line and if i got
a laugh i would be like well that joke's
done
i can move on now and now after you do
it for a bunch of years you're like well
there's more
more to it because let's get in there
what are these other people you're gonna
rewrite you're gonna do this special of
your old
first special re-done rewritten entirely
uh it's i'm so [ __ ] psyched for
people to hear but here's another thing
that i
i'm i'm doing it all myself you know
funding
shooting funding shooting i'm tired of
those companies telling us
what we're gonna make who can see it
when they can see it
this is our art this is our [ __ ]
and so i'm asking people man just come
check it out like i i want to take the
power out of these big [ __ ] and
put it back in the hands
of the people and slowly turning that
way yeah so you've kind of always been
on the forefront of it we give andrew
you know because he's you know he's kind
of the first in
the younger space student you've been
doing it longer than andrew schultz as
far as
putting it on youtube and all that stuff
yeah so like
and this is gonna be i'm hoping people
can jump on board and
and uh because the as soon as one of us
is like hey this is what this payday was
those companies are going to be like
yikes yeah no one talks about it which
is where it's going to be
it gives everyone 100 same with ufc i'm
like if you guys would just tell them
how much you actually made
when i negotiate it's going to help me
out tremendously so what i'm planning on
what's like podcasters guys
in uh austin and he's trying to podcast
tell me i'm like dude they're [ __ ]
you
because this is how much eventually if
you can get to this mark this how much
you're going to make a month
he's like why i'm like yeah and they
know that mm-hmm but that but no one
really talks
podcasters like especially big they
don't talk about the deals
yeah and the other because they're
scared that like maybe they're getting
[ __ ] but the only way to figure out if
you're getting [ __ ] is
for me to ask you because this is what
they're giving me for these numbers yeah
is this a good deal is this a good deal
right and so what i really want to do is
with this
i'm i'm happy to open up the books and
show everybody hey guys
this is how many people this is what i
charge think about this this is this
what you should do
so you do the video and then like i
don't know three or four months later
like this is the pros have shoot behind
the scenes that's where we're going to
cut it up and then be like this is the
process this is how much it cost me
this is the return i got after five
months these are the views that i got
these are the ticket sales i do now like
this is the avenue you guys should be
going down
and here's what i wanted to get mark
norman dude i know man but he sucked off
mark norman
you know he's over 5 million views mark
called me
because when it started and by the way
my mind's over 5 million views also
but but he called me he was like what do
you think i'm like dude
youtube unless unless you're chappelle
and
netflix is going to back up that truck
man i think something crazy like 72
percent of comedy is on
viewed on youtube and you're making all
of your money
passive income plus you get to choose
when p when you put it out how much you
put out
all of that [ __ ] there's another key
component there with netflix too
whether it's dave chappelle seinfeld
rogan mark maron bill burr
the analytics on that every single
special they
people stop it at 28 minutes in yeah
yeah every special stop that oh damn
they're 28 minutes and then
they'll come back to it or they don't
come back to it at all so if you know
that
it's like well then why won't i just do
a 30 minutes if i know
the average length is around 28 30
minutes why am i doing this entire hour
why would i break up into two half an
hour so here's what i here's what i
think i'm gonna do moving forward
i'm doing this special i have another
hour
ready in the can guys i i've traveled so
much and you know how much i've been
touring
yeah that i had about two
hours and 20 minutes of material just
kind of that i would float around and
depending on the show depending on what
kind of
but here's what i think i'm gonna do i'm
gonna do this special and then from here
on out i think every three months i'm
gonna put out 20 minutes of material
on youtube and i'm just going to put it
out
and i think that's going to be the way
to go because i'm with you not everybody
watches the full hour
no we know for a fact yeah and you know
what if you just keep putting things out
you're reminding people here i am here i
am here i am you know what i mean it's
an hour is a commitment especially now
20 minutes
do you know what i mean yeah not too bad
and so i think i'm going to do that and
whether i put out the 20 minutes all at
once or in 10-minute increments
however throughout the month dude you
know there was a story
in my in the father of the year special
that was
all together about 27 or 28 minutes
and i just broke it up into four pieces
and released it part one part two part
three part four
and it just drew people to every right
it was a story about jacob
my son challenging me to a fight which
is which basically happens to all of us
yeah
but but it get drawn out man and i
that showed me like i don't need those i
don't need those people to get
this [ __ ] out they but they will
convince you that you need them
what's the models that we grew up on
right and all our heroes grow up on the
same models
and then if you go to netflix like hey
man i think my specials did good i'm
seeing numbers on the road
you'll never get the actual numbers no
and that's another thing youtube
will tell you the numbers facebook i'll
tell you the numbers you know you'll
[ __ ] know so if you go to just huge
if you go to comedian joshua.com
uh the ticket link is there um it's
gonna be live you can watch it live
saturday live saturday and it lives for
a week so if you can't make saturday
it's live saturday and like i said guys
i would appreciate you guys if you want
to come by and check it out
i'm really here's the thing also
i've never done a special one take right
there
live stream stand up special buy tickets
right there yeah i'll see either one but
i've never done a one take
what do you mean like one takes back two
or three i usually shoot two
two so i can kind of cut it up and but
this is it
and how about this because of covid and
because i just decided to do this two
months ago
i've only run this hour five times
i'm but i like that tightrope feeling
i love that pressure i
love that that fighter flight david
blaine
i love how you're not even going to look
back at it
man you like david blaine up in here
though
man i'm walking the same [ __ ] man you
like the cameraman with tombow
you're a nice guy you powered through
about
i was just gonna skip over yeah just
[ __ ] that
you're the john elway comedy yeah
that makes sense he likes brian psych
we're talking about pressure you said
like david blaine
you're the elon
man you like dr fountain
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this just run a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son